hi may raise deals with a lot of drama
high school family and a murderous blue
scarab embedded into his back Kashi da
the scarab was built by the reach an
interstellar race infamous for
subjugating whole planets were not
destroying them now as Blue Beetle hi
Mase struggles to wield a weapon of
destruction as a tool for good the reach
infiltrator is a marksman assassin who
injures from afar and then sprints for
the kill his marksman passive is reached
directive disrupt using a skill empowers
his next basic attack with additional
true damage the amount of additional
damage is determined by the targets
current health afterwards disrupt goes
on cooldown for several seconds energy
cannon charges and fires a shot that
deals attack damage to the first enemy
hit the shot will then explode dealing
lesser attack damage to nearby enemies
Blue Beetle can launch his scarab
scanner at a target location granting
vision the Scarab explodes after a long
duration and marks nearby enemies for a
short time alternatively Blue Beetle can
activate the skill a second time or use
his ultimate causing the Scarab to
detonate early damaging enemies marked
by the explosion will consume the mark
and deal additional true damage at the
hit by reach directive use stick and
move to dash a fixed distance while
firing four shots at enemies behind him
the shots auto target enemies and
consecutive shots against the same
target field reduced attack damage blue
beetles ultimate is infiltrator mode
which allows him to toggle between
marksman
for his assassin form has different
skills and a higher move speed
additional ranks of infiltrator mode
increase the potency of all skills in
that form except for reach directive in
assassin form his passive becomes
reached directive execute execute
functions like disrupt but its true
damage will increase based on the
targets missing health reach directive
uses the same cool down in either forms
use lethal measures to dash to an enemy
and deal attack damage while applying on
hit effects including execute use
hypersonics to emit a loud blast that
fears drones and creatures for a short
time if hypersonics hits enemy champions
it reduces their damage and marks them
for several seconds damage a marked
champion to consume the mark and deal
true damage as if affected by reach
directive attack with mandible taser to
deal attack damage and severely reduce
the targets news feed for a few seconds
because scarab scanner and hypersonic
supply true damage like reach directive
level the passive early for more
frequent true damage energy cannon is
great for poking at enemy champions and
can be used to last-hit drones while its
secondary area damage can be useful to
harass enemies behind drones try landing
direct hits for max damage you can set
up vision with scarab scanner placing it
in stealth pads while you fight drone
waves to use it offensively mark all
targets with scarab scanner and follow
up with energy cannon to damage your
targets and activate reach directive try
to save stick and move from moments when
you need to escape as it's a strong
deterrent against chasing enemies use
infiltrator mode when one or more enemy
champions
health lethal measures has a low
cooldown so it can be used frequently to
get close especially against low health
targets mandible tasers high slow can
help chase a fleeing enemy but can also
be used as an emergency escape if an
enemy champion uses an escape scale when
hit with mandible taser you can follow
up with lethal measures if enemy drones
stand between you and the fleeing
champion use hypersonics to clear out
nearby enemy drones and follow up with
lethal measures Blue Beetle skills at a
moderate pace so strong early credit
gain is vital essential artifacts
include Joe chills revolver soul taker
katana and Deathstroke's cleanly
huntresses crossbows cooldown reduction
helps activate reach directive more
often Batman's utility belt provides a
nice boost to health and further
cooldown reduction moreover it's active
skill purge is useful when slowed by
enemy champions blue beetles x-ray
vision grants 30 credits for each
surveillance camera destroyed while the
skill is active this can be used for
efficient camera clearing that reduces
the enemy's vision cual accruing credits
kick some butt and murder
indiscriminately as the reach
infiltrator Blue Beetle
you